oh this is the core singers dude this
tracer my googa gaga IQ too soon of
course done fit me
hey guys what's up get your PIN number
wait a minute you got on to real
Avengers I can tell hope gives it away
okay any people oh you have 78 last
year's combination bring it a wet
Wembley
whoo that was awesome come on spider-man
don't mess with I kill you everybody you
want
you move them organized here we go you
know him - whoa look at that new guy
who's that Edward
that's my cue I gotta go but I'm fine
with Captain American I stole his shield
not throw it at him how are you thinking
I'm with those amazing thing is never
have missus over here Rouge and I just
sort of slipped in Beijing the second
come in this we have been Walsall the
rich and the powerful I don't care about
us we'd pick up a stern Withings their
table scraps these alien bastards the
top you got to use the stuff they use
the world's change time we change to
wait only retreat next mission we'll
call you
kick it a little more med touring to be
a real asset to you that's not a hug I'm
just grabbing the tow for you
oh all right kid good luck out there I
want it collecting stuff from Avengers
battles and building these crazy weapons
this is my chance to prove myself
what if somebody died different story
right because that's on you I wanted you
to be better eight years was in trouble
from those bozos up in stark tower and
there's no faster than red tide shows he
thinks he can tear down everything that
go I got a plane full of brand-new
Avengers weaponry to load up we're going
to put them out of business
we're gonna take everything they got
you're not gonna stop me
[Music]
you know em - yeah delish
finally here we go
sitting here cold you have 500 only tick
population or combination haha
I didn't keep that suit yeah come for me
where's really retreat but next mission
we'll call you all right it's not a hug
dependence grab the top we're not there
yet
all right good good luck out there
hey Peter you're going tonight I can't
tonight I got the astark internship
what's up guys here's my report for
tonight I stopped the grandstand flights
go hey could you do me a favor hold on
to that there's anybody by oh I helped
this old lady and she bought me a churro
so that was nice
I just promised I could be doing more
wait a minute
you guys on the real event just hope
gives it away you move I'm working on
he's working for crazy dangerous mr.
Tator there are people who handle this
sort of thing can't you just be a
friendly neighborhood spider-man
activating parachute
the world's changing voice timely change
to my can't prove myself will you
Spanish Queen you gotta get better at
this part of the job I'm Stan oh I'm
intimidated
are we going what are you hiding
Peter
[Music]
I'm just kidding hunger by
there's a ton of other social systems in
here but we're all disabled by the
training wheels protocol because mr.
start treating me like a kid could you
are a kid yeah you can stop a boss with
his bare hands
you